The Joe Rogan Experience you must get
this a lot that people say things like
uh I know
I do this I do this in a kind of
self-deprecating way I often say oh I've
been lucky in this yeah and you know
very well that some you know a lot of
life is like for sure some of life is
like being in the right place at the
right time being able just being
able-bodied but then a lot of it is and
it's underplayed is is you also work
hard yes like
um and I realized some time ago that I I
use because I'm
born in bird and I I have that natural
tendency to like under
play something well I'm just lucky in
that and somebody said to me you
shouldn't do that you know you do work
very hard and I thought yes but like
saying well I've been lucky in that is a
nice way to say to other people oh I
haven't really had any input and you
don't need to particularly either it's a
sort of
it's a it's a flattering thing to say to
somebody else and which ignores which
ignores
what something actually I quote at the
end of the book wonderful phrase of
Branch Ricky I came across he said uh
luck is the residue of design hmm
luck is the residue of design
like what a lot of what we call luck
it has come about
through something other than charms like
so I used to say you're lucky to be born
in America
and on one level that's true which is
like you could have been born in in the
great pool things you could have been
born born in Mogadishu and it'd be a lot
worse
but there's also something that covers
up which is the luck is
is that people before you made good
choices
that meant that you are in a situation
which is more optimal
and it's not simply luck
that you have in America
the right to freedom of speech
like that's not simply like it's locking
that you were born here as opposed to
Mogadishu but it's not luck that America
ended up with that situation it is it is
the residue of design it's the
consequence of men and women making good
decisions
prudent decisions like not being crazily
short termist
setting up a state well
you know there's a great description in
a novel by Hillary mantel about the
French Revolution and the first days of
the meeting of the parliament after
they've killed the king
and she says
um you know they wanted to talk about
rights
and she said she says I'm a paraphraging
she says something like this was the day
to talk about laws
but rights were more attractive to talk
about so they put off the discussion of
laws for another day you know
and that's how you get what you got in
the terror and everything else and this
is the thing is that what you we have to
find a better way to understand what we
often mean by luck
you have luck in your life
sometimes because other people
have made good judgments that are
effectively for you before your time
yeah you know your politicians your
family and others it's not just it's not
just some wild whirly gig it's also
make prudent decisions make wise
decisions work hard and a lot more
and you'll find that you are what we
call lucky or luckier
don't do any of that stuff put
everything off all the time be lazy be
um
unmotivated
um you know blame other people all the
time for things that I think you could
correct yourself and you will find you
are the type of person that is described
as unlucky
it's it's it's it's
and it's the same with countries there
are countries we describe as unlucky
like Venezuela was like they weren't
just unlucky
they had the people around [ __ ]
unluckiest people in the world at the
moment practically but like it became a
and what we would call an unlucky
country because politicians made
catastrophic decisions
you know they have yet they have the
same energy sources uh same energy
resources as Norway
uh it's it's better to be in Norway than
in Venezuela and there's a reason which
is that people made better decisions
and
we we're very
unwilling to identify what those
decisions are
and what it is that leads to a good
outcome or a bad outcome which is really
strange because American exceptionalism
was always predicated on the idea that
you work hard and you can make something
in this country there was a big part of
the motto of what it meant to be an
American yeah